[Music]
revica
is with us in new york city hi revica
how are you
hi dave my name is riska thank you i'm
sorry riff guy i'm butchered you're
going to apologize
no problem it's not an easy name but
thank you so much for taking my call
um so my question is my husband and i
live in brooklyn
okay you wait a minute stop you cut out
when you said my husband and i live in
brooklyn and that's all we heard
try again okay can you hear me now yes
ma'am
okay so i'm a public school teacher my
husband is a chef
we both make a decent living we are
currently on baby steps 3b
we're saving for a down payment on a
house and
the more i think about the possibility
of buying a house in new york
the more i think about how it's a
catch-22 where
we'll have to factor in the cost of
property taxes the cost of housing is
astronomical
and it just seems like that we're going
to sacrifice
our decent living for our quality of
life
less time will be spent with family and
um you know
now in new york city they're mandating
um that teachers and all city workers
get the coven vaccine
so it just it just seems like they give
you a little bit of freedom
and then they take it away and so i'm
just wondering at what point
would you say it's okay to get up leave
new york and
move somewhere else
you've already moved yeah you you
already lived you're gone
there's nothing that you described here
that's staying the only part the only
thing that's that's left is your broken
heart because you actually love the
people in the area
you've got family in the area your
history in the area and your heart is
hurting
but you already left you're gone the
every day you stay from this point
forward as a decision
to be a little less joyful right
absolutely yeah you get you've already
analyzed it because
anytime we're going to leave or you know
leave a job leave a relationship leave
anything
henry cloud talks about this in the book
necessary endings
which you might want to pick up by the
way it'd be a nice this is one of my top
five of all time
yeah henry's a good friend of john's of
mine both and just a great guy
but in necessary endings he says you end
a relationship
with a place a job an item
a person a whatever
when you lose hope that it's going to
get better
right and so in after the any time after
you've lost hope that it's going to get
better
it's now lacking in intelligence and
wisdom to continue to
i mean he's not going to beat me anymore
he's not going to beat me anymore no i
know he's going to beat me
then it's time to end this relationship
you've lost hope that it's going to get
better
even in a toxic situation you've lost
hope that's going to get better and
you the reason john and i jumped on this
so fast is you very much described that
you have lost hope
that this is going to get better they've
taken your freedoms the prices are too
high
there's nothing there that the good
things there have been outweighed by the
bad things
long before you made this phone call in
your mind
so you've already made the call now you
need to act on it you all have a funeral
and then go living somewhere fun